WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT.
>> Ed: IN THE MEANTIME THE USS
ROOSEVELT’S COMMANDING OFFICER
HAS BEEN RELIEVED OF DUTY AFTER
RAISING ALARM BELLS OF A
GROWING NUMBER OF SAILORS SICK
WITH COVID-19 ON HIS AIRCRAFT
CARRIER.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN IS LIVE WITH
MORE ON THE STORY.
>> HOURS AFTER THE ACTING NAVY
SECRETARY FIRED CAPTAIN BRETT
CROZIER, HUNDREDS OF CREW
MEMBERS GATHERED ON THE USS
ROOSEVELT HANGAR BAY TO GIVE
HIM A ROARING SEND-OFF CHANTING
HIS NAME.
114 SAILORS HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID-19 ABOARD
THE AIRCRAFT CARRIERS.
THE CREW IS IGNORING GUIDELINES
TO SOCIAL DISTANCE TO SEND A
MESSAGE OF PROTEST TO TOP NAVY
BRASS FOR FIRING THEIR SKIPPER
WHO SOUNDED ALARM BELLS ABOUT
THE RISING NUMBER OF
CORONAVIRUS CASES ON HIS SHIP
FORCED TO ARRIVE IN GUAM A WEEK
EARLY.
>> I DID NOT COME TO THIS
DECISION LIGHTLY.
I HAVE NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT
CAPTAIN CROZIER DID WHAT HE
THOUGHT WAS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE SAFETY AND
WELL-BEING OF HIS CREW.
UNFORTUNATELY IT DID THE
OPPOSITE.
IT UNNECESSARILY RAISED ALARMS
WITH THE FAMILIES OF OUR
SAILORS AND MARINES WITH NO
PLAN TO ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS.
>> ON SUNDAY CAPTAIN CROZIER
WROTE A LETTER THAT LEAKED TO
HIS HOMETOWN NEWSPAPER THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHRONICLE.
IN THE LETTER HE IS URGING
SENIOR NAVY LEADERS TO OFFLOAD
MOST OF THE 5,000 SAILORS ON
BOARD IMMEDIATELY TO DISINFECT
THE SHIP ADDING THE SPREAD OF
THE DISEASE IS ONING AND
ACCELERATING.
WE ARE NOT AT WAR.
SAILORS DON’T NEED TO DIE.
IF WE DON’T ACT NOW WE’RE
FAILING TO PROPERLY TAKE CARE
OF OUR MOST TRUSTED ASSET, OUR
SAILORS.
THE ACTING NAVY SECRETARY SAID
HE ACTED EMOTIONALLY WITHOUT
DISCUSSING THE LETTER WITH HIS
IMMEDIATE STRIKE GROUP
COMMANDER WHO IS JUST DOWN THE
HALL ON BOARD THE SHIP.
INSTEAD THE LETTER WAS SENT
OVER AN INSECURED, UNCLASSIFIED
EMAIL SYSTEM.
>> HAS A CHILLING EFFECT ON
OTHER NAVY CAPTAINS.
>> WHAT HE DID BY DOING THIS
AND NOT BEING CAREFUL WITH WHO
THAT INFORMATION WENT TO BUT IT
WAS COPIED TO 20 OR 30 OTHER
PEOPLE.
OKAY?
THAT IS JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE.
HE DID NOT TAKE CARE.
WHAT THAT DID IS CREATE A PANIC
-- A LITTLE BIT OF PANIC ON THE
SHIP.
>> AS WE SAID HE HAD NO
EVIDENCE THE CAPTAIN LEAKED THE
LETTER TO HIS HOMETOWN
NEWSPAPER BUT SUGGESTED THE
NAVY WAS ALREADY EXPEDITING
HELP FOR THE SHIP INCLUDING
ARRANGING 1700 HOTEL ROOMS IN
GUAM WHEN THE LETTER APPEARED